let's just grind build these events and
make money
ten thousand year thirty thousand
therefore let's save it let's [ __ ]
for two or thirty let's make a pact
everybody in two or thirty same things
safe [ __ ] collapses you're buying
million dollar homes for a hundred
thousand dollars catch on the next swing
game over and if I could tell you as
when you're a 37 year old dude you just
feel just as much like a 22 year old
dude and when you're a 37 year old dude
with millions of dollars all those
things you wanted to do in your twenties
or thirties you can catch up macro way
I'm mom doesn't got a crowd I graduate
[ __ ] background like a vegetable a taxi
with clarity hustle my my name is Gary
Thomas I've been telling you how
accountability I'll triple a given a
pedigree convenient a special my
specialty including the work that I'm
doing are the moving furniture 11 today
is a day we head to my house for the
Fantasy Baseball Draft super excited a
couple quick morning meetings and then
away we go time [ __ ] swim
yes
[Music]
and not being a place where if it's free
you know it's not on me right like I
think the best thing I can do to empower
people is actually show p4 how to do it
and then do it and then and motivate
them to do it and make them think I'm a
lot of my behavior is to make kids think
I'm cool a lot of reasons I do what I do
is to make things because I know if they
think I'm cool they're more likely to do
what I do and then I'm able to suck out
and like if I let the scam artist be the
cool ones then they're going to do that
but if I'm even cooler than them then
they'll do what I do the right way so
like see where I'm going so so if you're
really passionate about helping people
you're not going to do it in this model
because you're going to attract the
people that can't do really trying to
help my community but I'm asking nothing
from them in return not charging them
I'd have a much bigger reach than
everybody else
the biggest thing so it's anything for
me to give the advice because I'm not
full of [ __ ] right I like I'm I'm
telling you what I'm doing and the cool
part is you guys know I'm doing it like
you know what how I look different than
people that want to sell the one
thousand dollar course version of it
then I mean it's just real yeah it's
just super real and I know that I'll be
here in twenty twenty two and twenty
twenty-nine and twenty forty one and the
others won't not because I'm a genius
but because I study what's always
happened in life and so like to me I've
now in this weird position I found
myself is like I mean the place where
I'm like passionate to have both
versions of this vibe right because like
I especially can help the vibe that's
like high-energy and like like like if
you choose what you want to look at the
biggest reason I don't have way more
followers is because people come in and
they pick themselves out immediately
because they don't want to say too much
truth they want to go follow people that
put money on beds and take a photo of it
you know they don't want to deal with
what I'm talking about and but there's a
big difference like this is not what
those people's companies look like they
look like rented houses in like fancy
places
there's a big difference man depletion
economy's been good this is all spurred
up to good they died I'm just trying to
be really really good advice I want some
guys to win you'll happy you know what
if nothing else it could use something
else to think about as you're playing
chess you know cool thank you guys thank
you yeah thank you - thank you I love it
all right C letter G
[Music]
the
let's go
mr. bata check yes nice to meet here's
to meet you man
good luck
alright guys trying to make a daily deal
make it a little meaty for you because I
know it's a short day short day because
I'm going to a weekend where we're doing
fantasy baseball 20 homies coming in
we've been doing it for 20 years Fantasy
Baseball Draft is on Sunday we've never
done this before actually seven or eight
years ago we went to Atlantic City
but people coming this afternoon to my
house people coming in tomorrow morning
and then Sunday we draft some super
excited super important to have two
three four five six things in your lives
that are escapism that that don't matter
but matter so much I care more about
Fantasy Baseball Draft and the Jets than
I do about any account that I work with
at vaynermedia and I think you need to
have that balance of extremism when
you're this intense this on so if you're
somebody like me make sure you find
three or four things that don't matter
at all that create that balance that
place where you can dump all the
intensity of your life into and that's
what this weekend is going to be for me
that's a little fun fact another quick
little fun fact is is that you've been
having some really awesome meetings
where it's just getting very obvious to
me that this world we all live in is
just very real I mean this is it this is
the remote control of our society if you
are not thinking about and it is all we
know this is the punchline whatever
you're trying to achieve become an
artist become a t-shirt entrepreneur
become a politician become a real estate
mogul become a video superstar become an
actress an NBA player stick with me here
whatever you're doing politicians
selling coconut-water whatever you're
doing it's all all of your strategic
energy isn't against how do I
communicate that through this device and
the five to seven channels Facebook
Twitter Instagram snapchat LinkedIn you
know the channels that live on that
world how do I do that in this device
and on those channels that's it that's
it that's it pot committed chips in and
how do I become a great storyteller
contextually in all of them right iTunes
podcast or YouTube video
or articles on my blog or medium Google
AdWords Facebook Ads snapchat filter
marketplace influencer marketing
regardless of what you're trying to
accomplish
you've got to tell the world about it
this is now the world you're not betting
on this finished you're not betting on
this you're finished you're not betting
on this you're finished I don't think
you have to fully abandon that okay but
you need to find you need to make sure
that the cadence of the amount of hours
you put in Syngenta to great knowing
you'll have your whole life to live like
I don't know what your family situation
in the lake I got it so deep no it's so
broad so like unwavering makes sense why
it works is like no sugar on top of
every inches
sometimes it's the only way to win it's
got to win you can't you can um can't
hedge every hedge creates never go away
dude you should learn YouTube hacking do
it what were you here for right like
like if you become great at it and you
decide do things with me you'll be more
valuable to me if you know what will be
good for you like an hour a night that's
what's cool like because then you can
like be more valuable to yourself and to
us just a win-win situation but it's
work you start learning how to but you
know boss but it also may make you film
in a way differently yeah for sure
Wow Justin listen that'd be like hey
Gary you can do the crit like it may not
eat but even just trying for a couple of
uh yeah months yeah exactly
mm-hmm also at some point like maybe
later this year um like to actually like
have to sit down like drink with you or
something like that like don'twe talk
don't wait that long to the next 60 days
what do you wanna jump out like
strategies I guess for a chat
yeah like I feel like so much more
interaction just like running around
like I'm in now something like real
people all the strategic stuff the world
to do it would love to
get to learn a lot by watch me huh it's
so interesting night the other thing you
learned your unders a lot but just like
I don't waste a [ __ ] second any more
I just like constant with motion
crazy right cool that's a good way to
end the episode let everybody hear that
I'm serious
[Music]